veamos si podemos encontrar el producto
de x menos 4 x x 7 y además lo queremos
escribir en su forma desarrollada
también conocida como forma polinómica
pero bueno eso lo único que nos dice es
que queremos expresar este producto de
esta forma okay donde tenemos un
coeficiente por x al cuadrado más otro
coeficiente por el término x de primer
grado más una constante
ok esta es la forma desarrollada por la
forma polinómica esta es la forma en la
que queremos expresar este producto
y te recomiendo que le pongas una pausa
al vídeo y lo intentes por tu cuenta
bueno vamos a trabajarlo poco a poco la
idea cuando estamos multiplicando dos
binomios o bueno de hecho cuando estamos
multiplicando cualquier polinomio es
recordar la propiedad distributiva que a
estas alturas todos conocemos súper bien
y aquí como lo podemos ver es que vamos
a distribuir toda esta expresión x menos
4 en x y 7
así es que esto de aquí es igual a x
menos 4 por x más x menos 4 por 7 y
ahora pues tenemos que escribir esto
porque hoy tenemos x menos 4 x x que es
igual a x
or x4 y esto es simplemente la
multiplicación de x 4 por x luego
tenemos que sumar 7 por x 4 y observa lo
único que hicimos fue distribuir el x 4
lo que tomamos esta expresión x menos 4
y la multiplicamos por cada uno de los
términos de esta otra expresión ok
tenemos x por x menos 4 y tenemos 7 por
x menos 4 y ahora por aquí tenemos estos
dos términos separados y bueno para
simplificar cada uno de estos términos
para hacer estas multiplicaciones
tenemos que usar otra vez la propiedad
distributiva en este caso tenemos que
distribuir el x y en este otro caso
tenemos que distribuir el 7 así es que
vamos a hacer eso que hay por aquí
tenemos x por x
es x al cuadrado y también tenemos x x
menos 4 y eso es menos 4x y así
obtenemos x al cuadrado menos 4x y por
acá tenemos 7 x x entonces tenemos 7 x
7 x menos 40 7 x menos 4 es menos 28 y
ya casi terminamos pero esto se puede
simplificar más porque tenemos aquí dos
términos de primer grado y si tengo
menos 4x y a eso le sumó 7 x que es lo
que nos queda
bueno pues de estos dos términos lo que
nos queda es menos 47 x menos 4 más 7 x
y aquí realmente lo único que estoy
haciendo es que quede muy claro que
estamos sumando estos dos coeficientes y
también tenemos los otros términos x al
cuadrado y menos 28 y ahora sí ya
estamos a punto de terminar
ok porque esto se simplifica a x al
cuadrado
- 47 estrés entonces aquí tenemos 3x
en estos dos términos de primer grado se
simplifican en 3x y luego tenemos menos
28 menos 28 y listo ya terminamos ya lo
escribimos de esta otra forma porque hay
aquí uno es a 3 es b y menos 28 s pero
hay un patrón que sería muy interesante
que observemos aquí sobre todo cuando
estamos multiplicando dos binomios como
estos que tienen un 1 como coeficiente
de la x con estos binomios es más fácil
observar el patrón aunque tenemos x por
equis que nos da x al cuadrado luego
tenemos menos 4 por 7 que nos da menos
28 y luego como obtuvimos este término
de enmedio de aquí pues lo obtuvimos de
menos 4 x + 7 x o lo que es lo mismo lo
obtuvimos de menos 47
x y aquí es donde se pone muy
interesante porque eso lo podemos ver
por aquí como menos cuatro más 7 x x así
es que aquí tenemos un patrón siempre
que estemos multiplicando dos binomios
donde el coeficiente de las x sea 1 el
primer término va a ser x al cuadrado el
último término va a ser la
multiplicación de estas dos constantes y
el término de primer grado su
coeficiente va a ser la suma de estas
dos constantes no que hay menos cuatro
más siete menos 47 ahora este patrón te
puede servir muchísimo para hacer la
multiplicación de binomios mucho más
rápido pero no hay que perder de vista
de dónde salió ese patrón y salió de
aquí simplemente utilizando la propiedad
distributiva dos veces